we have this uh liel that the Lites were
anti- technology and they're anything
but right to be a skilled uh textile
trades person in the early 19th century
you needed to do a seven-year
apprenticeship this is the equivalent of
getting a master's degree in engineering
from MIT right and their bosses built
machines that made very lowquality
textiles but were so easy that children
could use them and the point was that
they could kidnap children from uh
Napoleonic War orphanages in London and
denture them to 10 years of service in
the dark satanic Mills of Manchester
maim them starve them mutilate them and
kill them in the teeth of the machine
and make gigantic profits without uh
having to do any kind of bargaining with
their existing Workforce and throw the
workforce on the on the rubbish heap of
history that was what the Lites objected
to right to call the Lites anti- machine
is like calling Osama Bin Laden anti-
Aviation the thing they were angry about
was not the
machines